lareska
says that it was his dream come true
when he won homecoming queen right here
at durango high school but it's what
came later that they're now speaking out
about so this doesn't happen to anyone
else
you are loved you are perfect i pulled
out a pride flag that was hiding in my
back pocket and put it around as a cape
17-year-old senior josh ocampo-laresca
speaking out after attending homecoming
saturday night at durango high school
ocampo loresco was named homecoming
queen a proud member of the lgbtq plus
community josh pulled out their pride
flag and gave a speech in which they
shared with fellow students to love
oneself that speech quickly turned into
acapellaresca being walked off by school
administration ocampolareska says they
were told prior that flags of any kind
were not allowed at school but told it
was the commotion of the speech that led
to them getting in trouble i was talked
to by administration and i was told not
to pull it out because of any political
statement it might carry my identity
should not be controversial in any sense
of the matter and with or without the
flag sunday josh's family spoke to
school officials and josh is no longer
facing any type of disciplinary action
but josh and their friend alex say it's
important they feel comfortable at
school and that everyone is accepted for
who they are the ones that do get to
rare pride at school should not be
punished in any way or told that they
can't do that even if it is
covered with a different narrative
josh plans on going back to school on
monday and says the school
administration has since apologized for
the misunderstanding they say on their
part reporting live from durango high
school madison kimbrough live local now